we already know the derivatives of sine
and cosine we know that the derivative
with respect to x
of sine
of x
is equal to cosine of x
we know that the derivative with respect
to x of cosine of x is equal to negative
sine of x
and so what we want to do in this video
is find the derivatives of the other
basic trig functions so in particular we
know let's figure out what the
derivative with respect to x let's first
do tangent of x
tangent of x
well this is the same thing as trying to
find
the derivative with respect to x of
well tangent of x is just sine of x
sine of x over
cosine of x
and since it can be expressed as a as as
the quotient of two functions we can
apply the quotient rule here to to
evaluate this or to to figure out what
this is going to be the quotient rule
tells us that this is going to be
the derivative of the top function which
we know is cosine of x
times the bottom function
which is cosine of x so times
cosine of x
minus
minus
the top function which is sine of x
sine of x times the derivative of the
bottom function so the derivative of
cosine of x is
negative sine of x so i could put the
sine of x there but where the negative
can just cancel that out
and it's going to be over
over
the bottom function squared so cosine
squared of x
now what is this
well
what we have here this is just cosine
squared of x this is just sine
squared of x and we know from the
pythagorean identity and this is really
just out of comes out of the unit circle
definition the cosine squared of x plus
sine squared of x well that's going to
be equal to 1 for any x
so all of this is equal to 1. and so we
end up with 1 over cosine squared x
which is the same thing as
which is the same thing as secant of x
squared
one over cosine of x is secant so this
is just secant of x squared so that was
pretty straightforward now let's just do
the inverse of the or you could say the
reciprocal i should say of the tangent
function which is the cotangent so that
was fun so let's do that d dx
of cotangent not cosine
of cotangent
of x
well
same idea that's the derivative with
respect to x
and this time
so let me make some sufficiently large
brackets
so now this is cosine of x
over sine of x
over sine of x but once again we can use
the quotient rule here
so this is going to be the derivative of
the top function which is negative we're
doing that magenta color
that is
negative sine
of x
times the bottom function
so times sine of x
sine of x
minus
minus
the top function cosine of x
cosine of x
times the derivative of the bottom
function which is just going to be
another cosine of x
and then all of that over
the bottom function squared so sine
of x squared
now what does this simplify to up here
let's see this is
sine squared of x
although we have a negative there minus
cosine
squared of x but we could factor out the
negative and this would be negative
sine
squared of x plus cosine squared of x
well this is just 1 by the pythagorean
identity and so this is negative 1 over
sine squared x negative 1
over
sine
squared x
and that is the same thing as
negative
co
secant squared of i'm running out of
space
of
of x there you go